[Music]
on this wednesday night promises for the
next session of parliament in a pandemic
what the throne speech revealed this is
not the time
for austerity the plans to fight covid19
boost the economy and get women back in
the workforce plus
the pledge for a national child care
program
teddy bears down on nova scotia the
damage
the power outages and who's bracing for
impact next
and a liberal lioness lies in repose
she was really all about advancing all
people
ruth vader ginsburg's final journey to
the u.s supreme court
global national with donna friesen
good evening and thanks for joining us
these are extraordinary times and we
begin tonight with a couple of political
firsts
a federal speech from the throne
delivered in the middle of a pandemic
as well as an address to the nation by
prime minister justin trudeau
he declared that a second wave of kobit
19 is underway in canada's four biggest
provinces
and he said time is running out to turn
it around
we're on the brink of a fall that could
be much worse than the spring
i know this isn't the news that any of
us wanted to hear
it's all too likely we won't be
gathering for thanksgiving
but we still have a shot at christmas
the prime minister said canada is at a
crossroads an appeal to all of us not to
let our guard down on public health
restrictions like masks and physical
distancing
and he repeated some of the lines from
the throne speech
delivered earlier today
never has a throne speech been delivered
in the middle of a pandemic
masks physical distancing far fewer mps
present than usual
the leader of the opposition was not
there nor was the leader of the block
quebecois both have covid19
and are self-isolating it is 2020 and
the virus is certain to dominate
politics in the months ahead
there was a great deal of talk today for
more detail let's go to abigail beeman
and ottawa abigail start with the prime
minister's
address to the nation tonight well donna
in that address the prime minister began
with a stark picture of where we are he
said when the country entered
lockdown in march there were 47 new
cases
yesterday alone there were more than a
thousand trudeau then moved into all of
the major
further investments he's promising in
the throne speech defending his decision
to keep spending money
i know some people are asking how we can
afford to do all this for canadians
that's fair that low interest rates
mean we can afford it and in fact doing
less
would end up costing far more
doing less would mean a slower recovery
and bigger deficits in the long run
the throne speech laid out lots of plans
to spend but offered
no financial details immediate help in
the fight against the virus was the
first of four pillars in that throne
speech
have a look this is not the time
for austerity anything but austere
there's a long list of promises
many we've heard before but there's
never been a throne speech
during the coven 19 pandemic as cases
climb the liberals are offering
immediate help for things like
faster testing canadians should not be
waiting in line for hours to get a test
and more money for businesses forced to
close through potential
new targeted lockdowns the government
will extend the wage subsidy through the
summer
revamp bi and help specific industries
such as travel and hospitality
the speech offers national strategies
for long-term care
housing pharmacare creating a child care
system and a disability benefit program
they've promised pharmacare since the
late 90s and
has not been achieved they've been
really good at saying the right words
but not so good at actually delivering
the action the government will launch a
campaign to create
over one million jobs on the much talked
about green shift
the liberals say climate action is the
cornerstone of that jobs plan
canada cannot reach net zero without the
know-how
of the energy sector and the innovative
ideas of all canadians
including people in places like british
columbia alberta
saskatchewan and newfoundland and
labrador they plan to legislate that
goal of net zero emissions by 2050 and
stick to their promise to ban single-use
plastics
and in a broad ranging speech they've
recommitted to reconciliation with
indigenous peoples
fighting systemic racism they even call
for michael coverig and michael spavor
detained in china
to be brought home conservatives cannot
support it
it is another speech that is full of
liberal
buzzwords and grand gestures with very
little to no
follow-up plan now conservative leader
aaron o'toole also addressed the nation
tonight but did so from outside his home
he's in isolation after testing positive
for kovid 19 along with his wife
tonight o'toole appeared to be in good
health
today mr trudeau told millions of
canadians that building back better
doesn't include their family i believe
we need to build back
stronger as a country we must be more
resilient and self-reliant for the
future
abigail it felt a little bit like
election talk even though
it seems talk of a fall election has
vanished this is a minority government
though how will this parliament function
in the pandemic especially given
the leader of the conservatives and the
bloc both have coveted 19.
well just minutes before we heard that
speech from the throne we learned
there's an agreement between parties for
a
hybrid parliament going forward for now
mps will vote remotely by
video there is an app for that in the
works and there's no date yet scheduled
for that
confidence vote donna all right abigail
beeman in ottawa thanks and our
ottawa bureau chief mercedes stevenson
is standing by mercedes no
federal government has had to navigate
through a public health crisis
like this the prime minister asked
tonight for time on all the networks to
speak directly to canadians
what struck you about what he said well
donna what struck me
was what he said off the top the level
of concern he was expressing about those
increasing numbers and i think
there's no doubt that the prime minister
wanted to send a very serious message
that people
have to stick to their careful measures
washing your hands wearing a mask
maintaining social distancing he warned
that otherwise we are looking at a fall
that will be far worse than what we saw
in the spring and that if there's any
hope of having a shot
at christmases together we will have to
crack down now
i think that was a very clear message
from the prime minister and similar to
the type
that we saw him delivering earlier in
the pandemic when he used to speak to
canadians outside of his house every day
but then there was the throne speech 2.0
element of all of this
where he basically reiterated all the
things abigail just briefed us on
arguing to canadians that the federal
government has their back
therefore you can stay home you can
relax let us take care of everything but
no doubt
that was an opportunity to make sure
that those words came from the prime
minister's mouth
and are quoted and not the governor
generals mercedes the prime minister
asked canadians tonight to stay strong
to work together to keep the coveted
numbers from rising any further
are our federal political leaders likely
to work together as well in this next
session of parliament
i suspect they will at least initially
and we'll have to see where this all
plays out because donna as you know in
politics
a very difficult thing to predict we do
know this the conservatives
will not support the throne speech
they've already said that
e francois blanchette put down an
ultimatum tonight saying if the federal
government doesn't give quebec
health transfers with no strings
attached he'll vote against it well
that leaves things in the hands of the
ndp they've said that they want paid
sick care and an extension of the serb
that's certainly not out of the realm of
possibility for the government
they only need one opposition party to
back them
and there's certainly a sense that
canadians aren't looking for an election
in a time where we're seeing these
pandemic numbers increasing donna
all right mercedes stevenson thank you
and now
to the topic of child care today's
throne speech points out that it's been
nearly 50 years since the royal
commission on the status of women deemed
child care
essential for women's social and
economic equality
anyone with young children especially
single moms no it is still
expensive and hard to find and covet 19
has made the need
even more acute the government is
promising a significant
long-term sustained investment to create
a canada-wide
early learning and child care system
what that will be whether it will be
enough to create
universal child care well we don't know
because that as jeff semple explains is
what advocates
say is needed fernanda yancha paxy
knows all too well the challenges of
child care
the mother of two has juggled a job
while also working on a phd
and after three years on a daycare
waiting list she could barely afford it
i had been using my scholarship to be
able to pay for her daycare
but the pandemic proved the breaking
point months away from graduation
she put her studies on hold it's
certainly a hard decision because i know
that it's really hard for a woman to go
into the
job market before covet letting alone
now
but i didn't have any other options this
recession has hit working women
hard in the first two months of the
pandemic one and a half million canadian
women lost their jobs
plummeting their participation in the
workforce to a 30-year low
and having a tougher time getting back
into the economy
because of lack of safe school reopening
and lack of even availability of child
care
you have to say that it's been the aha
moment martha friendly has worked on
child care policy for 50 years and
welcomes the government's promise to
create a canada-wide child
care system each province and territory
would sort of have certain policy
levers but one of the principles
already from the federal government is
it should be affordable
similar subsidized systems already exist
in europe
and in quebec that province's 2 billion
a year program
introduced in the 90s saw a spike in
women joining the workforce
there is a general consensus that it has
been good for
the quebec economy and it has been good
for quebec households as well
before the pandemic women's
participation in the canadian workforce
was eight percent lower than men
the international monetary fund says
closing that gap would boost canada's
gdp
by four percent we can't have a recovery
without a she covered
and we can't have a she covered without
child care
that's an economic argument that's not a
feminist argument
50 years since the first calls for
universal child care
the pandemic may finally get things
rolling
jeff several global news toronto
the ontario government says up to 60
pharmacies across that province will
begin offering covid 19 tests starting
on friday
the government hopes the initiative will
reduce pressure on the province's 147
assessment centers people have been
lining up at them for hours
the pharmacy tests will be appointment
only and are only for people with no
symptoms of covid19
the test will be free at participating
pharmacies ontario reported 335 new
cases of covid19 today
a big drop from the 478 cases reported
yesterday
an outbreak of kobit 19 inside alberta's
largest hospital is putting a strain on
staff
and patients three people have now died
and more than 100 healthcare workers are
in self-isolation
health officials are investigating how
the virus spread and as heather urex
west explains there are fears that may
have been circulating in the hospital
undetected for weeks when an outbreak
was first declared at calgary's
foothills hospital
officials warned the number of
infections was likely to rise they
were right across three units there are
now more than 26 cases of the virus
and three elderly patients have died
with
increasing numbers in the community even
if it's in younger people that for
example
tend to experience less severe disease
not fully protected but tend to be less
severe
they can still be the vector that
transmits the disease to an at-risk
population
investigators still don't know how the
virus got into the hospital
at foothills contact tracers are going
back more than two weeks to determine
a source in the meantime more than 100
health care workers have been told to
isolate
alberta health services says all
vacancies are being covered
but those on the front lines say the
entire system is feeling the pressure
the reality is that we don't have a huge
pool of
skilled nursing staff physicians
respiratory therapists
etc just waiting to come in and fill
these spots when people
are put off work because of exposures in
july a full
facility outbreak at edmonton's missouri
cordia hospital led to a complete
lockdown
and for more than a month the emergency
department was closed
but that's not the case now at any of
alberta's hospitals
and this doctor says it would be more
dangerous for patients if they were to
delay
care in order to stay away if you are
having symptoms of heart failure
shortness of breath whether you're
having chest pain
or having symptoms of stroke all these
people
should come to the hospital there had
been two other hospital outbreaks in the
province
one at calgary's peter lawhead has just
ended while a third at edmonton's royal
alex
has so far impacted only staff heather
urex west global news
calgary police in victoria b.c
say they are aware of threats made
against provincial health officer dr
bonnie henry
dr henry says she's had to have security
at her home she says she's received
death threats along with abusive letters
and her staff have had abusive phone
calls she says
she fears for her safety and that of her
team and believes the harassment is
partly due to
being a woman in a high profile position
you know how do we
deal with that um and i i
sense that people find that it's it's
okay
to do that for a woman who's up front
more so
than some of our male leaders dr henry
says she thinks it's important to
discuss these issues when trying to
mentor the next generation of leaders
she's become a much beloved national
figure during the covid19 pandemic often
receiving praise for her kind
calm demeanor in louisville kentucky
tonight protesters are again on the
streets they're angry a grand jury has
decided it will not
charge any officers directly for the
death of brianna taylor
one fired kentucky police officer brett
hankinson
is facing three charges but they are for
shooting into the apartments of taylor's
neighbors
if convicted he could face up to 15
years in jail the grand jury determined
the
two other officers who fired their
weapons were justified in their use of
force police burst into taylor's home on
march 13 as part of a botched
drug investigation no drugs were found
the 26-year-old was shot multiple times
a spokesperson for the family's attorney
says they are not satisfied
essentially the judgment that was
released
states that black people are the only
people
in this country who are blamed for their
own unjust killing
by law enforcement the announcement
essentially is just
partial justice and certainly rhonda
taylor
deserves full justice the family hopes
an ongoing fbi investigation into
potential violations of federal law will
provide taylor with
justice teddy storms into nova scotia
coming up the mess it left behind
post tropical storm teddy has already
whipped across nova scotia and is now
churning up the seas in the gulf of st
lawrence it has weakened but there are
still tropical
storm and storm surge warnings in place
for southwestern newfoundland tonight
nova scotia took the brunt of the storm
this morning the center of it passed
over the eastern part of that province
and cape breton
and our ross lord watched it happen
teddy's impact pales in comparison to
some previous storms like 2003's
hurricane
juan and last year's dorian but where it
hit directly
it hit hard
in aeroshed on cape breton island the
storm packed vicious winds of 100
kilometers an hour
that's the way the wind way to wind
direction is this year is a lot worse
here in this area so
my eavesdropping stuff there and stuff
blowing off and
just the regular stuff that happens your
hurricane powers out right now and
so down got the generator going
thousands of other homes and businesses
also lost power
in villages like these that are
completely exposed to the storm
the roar of the waves and the howling
winds can be exhilarating
but for people who live up and down this
coast it's unnerving too
our boats and everyone else in the
community needs any help
they're all going to stick together on
this one we're going to keep an eye on
it and that's all we can do
aside from flooding in low-lying areas
other parts of the province were mostly
unscathed
meteorologists say teddy spent much of
its energy
transitioning from a hurricane to a
post-tropical storm
before arriving in nova scotia storm
surges that have knocked out roads and
fishing wars previously
never materialized from a system whose
punch had a big
impact on relatively few ross laura
global news
port hawkesbury nova scotia still ahead
a kremlin critic
on the road to recovery
russian opposition leader alexei navalny
is now doing well enough he's been
released from the german hospital where
he was taken
after being poisoned with the nerve
agent novichok navalny posted this today
saying he's recovering but the path will
be a long one
he says he's learning to stand on one
leg again and can't throw a ball with
his left hand
he was in a coma for days but doctors
say he does have a chance at a full
recovery
navalny is one of the most prominent
opponents of russian president vladimir
putin
novochuck has become a hallmark of
attacks on kremlin
critics in belarus alexander lukashenko
has been secretly sworn in for a sixth
term as president ignoring intense and
sustained protests
that the election was rigged
ceremony wasn't announced in advance the
disputed election was six weeks ago
lukashinka claims he won in a landslide
but the opposition and tens of thousands
of people in the country say the vote
was rigged
several european countries and the u.s
do not recognize him as the legitimate
president
of belarus next a final journey to the
court ruth bader ginsburg
served on for decades
the u.s has begun three days of tributes
to the late supreme court justice
ruth bader ginsburg she died on friday
at the age of 87.
she'd served 27 years on america's
highest court
and today more than 100 of ginsburg's
former law clerks
stood at attention on the steps of the
supreme court
awaiting her arrival one last time
dignitaries and mourners from across the
u.s
also gathered to pay their respects as
jackson proskow reports ginsburg had a
significant impact on law
gender equality and later in life even
pop culture
she made one final journey of those
white marble steps
justice ruth bader ginsburg was carried
silently past an
army of her former law clerks and into
the supreme court
this was justice ginsburg's life's work
to insist that the constitution deliver
on its promise
at a private service there was high
praise from the chief justice
among the words that best describe ruth
tough
brave a fighter a winner later as
ginsburg lay in repose outside
americans paused in tribute including
bill
and hillary clinton it was the former
president who nominated her to the high
court
she protect women and men for the right
to live the right to vote she's someone
i've idolized for a long time
terence kane had the chance to meet
ginsburg when he was just
14. today he says he understands her
impact
the idea that equality under law
is necessary it's it's
it is law it is it is what we have to
believe in it's what we need
to succeed few believe there will be
another justice like rbg
especially with republicans expected to
confirm a new justice
ideologically opposite to ginsburg in
the coming weeks
i don't think we'll see the likes of her
again in our lifetime and so i wanted to
show her our respect at a critical
juncture in american history
the passing of this icon of equality may
bring about a legacy of its own
inspiring americans to fight for the
values bestowed upon them by this very
court jackson prosco global news
washington and that is global national
for this wednesday i'm donna friesen
we leave you tonight with an image of
parliament hill where the late john
turner served as prime minister in 1984.
it was announced this week a state
funeral will be held for turner on
october 6th in toronto though it won't
be open to the public
because of the pandemic john turner died
september 19th he was
91 years old thanks for watching
take care of yourselves bye-bye